The Joe Rogan experience and I don't know what I'm fighting again.
So,
but now I'm ready to be active.
That was a big part of my decision to go there too.
Uh,
and stay there a year is I want to be active this year to two fights.
But
training,
where do they have you rank now?
I don't think I am.
You don't think you ranked even Tom 15?
No,
definitely not.
Hmm.
What do you think you should do in terms of the next level of fighter you face?
Like what kind of guy would you like to fight?
Huh?
Man,
that's crazy.
I don't even ask myself those questions.
What do you do you just wait for the call?
Yeah,
I usually just,
I await for the call and whoever they,
they usually offer to,
they had like two options.
Really?
Yeah.
Like how do you choose?
Uh,
usually they offer like,
like the last time it was okay,
there's air candor's or there's a guy like,
I didn't even know his name.
Like this guy is going to be new coming into the UFC and Eric Anders is like
coming off a loss,
blah,
blah.
I'm like,
okay,
well sucks.
I know Eric,
all this stuff,
but I'd rather fight Eric because I've already lost three times to guys who are
making their UFC debuts and it's just not good for me.
But you know what I mean?
Like obviously they're tough,
they're hungry,
they're trying to get into the UFC.
It's going to be a really tough fight.
Um,
and so that's kind of how I made the decision.
The last one I was like,
I don't want to take the risk of losing another fight to a guy who is making his
debut because three times is enough for me.
That's refreshingly honest.
Yeah,
that's what,
yeah,
I mean it's like we were talking about earlier about boxers,
having managers that have a strategy to keep them undefeated as long as
possible,
give them tests,
have them decide like when's the right time to take this fight?
Once you know what's,
what's the right thing to do.
And as a professional,
how much of an advantage is it to know what a guy does?
Know who he is.
I've seen him fight a bunch of times.
Been around them.
Uh,
it's,
I just like just for instance,
um,
like I fought go con Saki and then they offered me Johnny Walker.
And so like Johnny Walker was coming off contenders series,
but still nobody knew.
Like not even,
we knew we saw his highlights,
but we're like,
oh well,
like
this,
look at the competition that he's faced.
Right.
You know,
so we didn't really get to see much of what he was capable of.
So I'm like,
uh,
okay.
If that's all you got,
then I'll take the fight by then.
Here comes Johnny Walker,
this like raging beast,
you know,
it'd be like the guy's huge.
So,
um,
yeah,
it was just,
it was weird.
Like,
so I went from beating go con Saki to losing Johnnie Walker.
Thank God Johnny Walker has been as good as,
he hasn't has made a name for himself but still like,
yeah,
I just didn't want to be like a,
I guess like a a foot in or what do they call it?
Like a a journeyman.
Yeah.
Not a journeyman,
but like when they say like you're trying to get like your foot in the door or
something like that,
like put the door guy.
Someone said it on Instagram.
I saw it like a few times,
but um,
yeah,
I just didn't want to like just be another guy that,
you know,
could possibly give somebody their shot into the UFC.
I was like,
don't let me fight a guy that's,
that's in the UFC this time.
Will,
so now that you did and you had the fight with Eric Anderson,
you have the spectacular result and now you know,
people recognizing that you,
you,
you've made some big improvement.
Like what caliber fighter,
like who,
who,
who do you think would propel your career?
Like what would be the best next step?
Uh,
I mean definitely I think it's time for me to break somewhere into the top 15,
you know,
for sure net nowhere in the guys that are at the very top because
they're all kind of tied up.
They're all pretty tied up,
you know?
And I definitely think it'll be a while before I can actually fight Jones
because just like how things are,
how things are laid out.
Like I know for sure Johnny walkers ranked and he's already kind of like in
talks like he's the guy to beat Jon Jones,
so sure they're going to try to set that up right.
And then there's like kind of the set of guys in the middle.
Um,
did Johnnie Walker fucking shoulder open news doing that worm thing?
Supposedly.
But I think he's fine.
I think he's fine because I've had people call me in like,
Hey,
I just see this Johnny Walker guy down,
done like on the street every day.
I guess he's back in Thailand now.
So he did that flop around thing and then he could,
when he got up he couldn't move.
His shoulder dislocate is located or something like that.
I think that's what happened.
That's so insane.
Did you,
were you calm after,
right?
Yeah.
I think you call it out like most like what's going on,
man?
Yeah.
He's um,
I hope he doesn't,
didn't permanently injured his shoulder.
Nah,
I think he might be fine.
I hope so.
Yeah.
He's not walking around in a slug or anything right now,
but he could have a little,
but yeah,
after your fight with him,
he's made quite an account of himself.
That last fight without flying knee was insane.
Yeah.
So I'm sure,
I'm sure before I get to the top,
I'd have to fight every game.
Right.
What's up,
Jim?
Yeah,
I would imagine that he is currently recuperating from his shoulder surgery
after dislocated shoulder surgery.
Dude.
Ah,
shoulder surgery,
that's never,
you're fucked up.
I've never known anybody to have shoulder surgery and come back with a full,
fully warranted Danage reward.
Had shoulder surgery and came back better than ever.
But he's also got the best doctors.
Sure.
Took a long time.
Two months from a comeback is what he says.
He goes to fight the winter months.
Anthony's Talman Smith,
he better take his time.
He doesn't want have a fuck a shoulder up forever,
you know,
if it rips again,
that's a great fight.
Anthony Smith and Gustafson,
And you know,
Anthony Smith Account,
he
really held his own,
like he made a good account of himself in that fight.
He didn't win the fight,
but you know,
he showed everybody how he is,
especially in that first round.
Yeah,
for sure.
Real good and sharp.
John's just pattern is just,
John's just better,
you know.
I mean for now he just has his number.
I mean in the John Jones that you're seeing now is a Jon Jones had sort of,
has like a real goal in mind.
Yeah.
He's had it taken away from them and it gave,
they gave it back to him and now he knows he has it and he's capitalizing
it seems like it,
it's like he knows what it's like to be,
to be the best,
but not be able to,
to really like do anything about it.
Right.
For a long amount of time.
Yeah.
So I think it's,
I think it's pretty cool to be able to see this version of him and,
and to be active around this time.
Maybe,
you know,
maybe I'll get a shot or maybe he'll still be around at the top.
Like whenever I get my shot.
[inaudible] how it goes.
If you had a timeline in your head of when you think you'd be ready to challenge
for a title,
when do you think it would be?
Uh,
oh,
I can give it
another year.
Yeah.
I think I can get one,
one more year,
a year and a half of good solid flights in to really solidify myself in just in
the UFC and uh,
and just put in the work and everything that,
that it,
that it takes to really embody what I think it would be like what I think it
would take to be a champion as successful champion.
Not just like get the belt and lose it,
you know,
like get the bell and then,
and then,
uh,
just be a champion for,
you know,
a couple months.
Like now to actually be a champion and,
and,
and hold it down.
I think
little over a year,
but it's an unbelievably talent rich wig class.
Right?
Cause de Cormier is still kind of in it.
[inaudible] Jon Jones is the champion.
You know,
he just got off the Anthony Smith Phi Anthony Smith,
Gustafson Gustafson still beast,
but no one is like really standing out as being like this person that everybody
wants to see challenge for the title.
You've got worthy challengers,
they're good fights,
but there's no one that you're seeing them except cornea was the only one we
seen him versus John.
You're like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is going to happen here?
What's going to happen here?
And that's what the division needs I think.
Yeah,
no,
definitely.
And that's something that
that I can also see and that's something that I also want to do for myself.
I just,
I want to be the best version and I'm starting to find out what that's like.
Especially like the happy,
like being able to do what I,
what I want to do and strike high.
I want to strike and stuff.
So now like let's get some,
some fights in there to mix it up.
Yeah.
Really like test that like test if it works,
test,
if that's really going to be able to,
to sustain and,
and what takes to get to get there.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm willing to test it.
Like if they want to put me up against the,
the best grappler in the world and thinks that I'll have no chance on the
ground.
Okay,
cool.
Or if they want to put me against,
well they already did.
They thought I wouldn't stand a chance against go on Saki and like I was very
happy for that because I go,
I'm like,
okay cool.
I get to test the best of my abilities.
Like that's like again,
so legend.
Yeah.
I didn't like,
I knew that I had everything it took to beat him but I,
I didn't think like Ah,
he's going to destroy me.
No,
never.
Like so I'm wanting to continue to be tested.
It's interesting your approach cause I wonder if the fact that you were such a
non confrontational guy and you are really easy
going helps you and that you have like less conflict in your head.
I almost,
I almost wonder because even the way you approach like these different match ups
and everything you like,
you kind of put your ego aside,
you're looking into like what is the smart thing to do here?
The smart thing to do is not take this fight against this newcomer guy.
I've already lost the newcomer guys.
The smart thing is,
okay,
we,
we realized that Thailand was extremely beneficial.
Let's fucking move to Thailand.
Yeah.
So you're doing all these like really,
really smart moves where you know,
you're,
you're looking at it very logically,
but you have confidence in yourself,
but you're not,
you don't really know like a braggy guy,
you know,
you're getting everything done with your work,
you're getting everything done with your results.
It's uh,
it's interesting to see me because you want to see as many different kinds of
fighters as possible and you're like a new
kind of thing.
That's the most important thing though,
man.
Like I,
I don't,
I don't really tune in too much UFC and like what's going on because of that
reason.
Right.
I don't care about what people have to say in this.
I don't watch fighting to hear what people have to say.
You know?
Like,
I didn't fight.
it's not about talking,
it's about fighting.
Right.
And the only thing that I can prove and have to prove is what I can do with my
skills.
That's it.
You know?
So like if they put me like
they put me against any type of other fighter,
like,
let's go back to the roots of mixed martial arts.
Let's go back to the roots of UFC.
Like when guys weren't even the same size and they were just matching up
different martial arts,
I'd be down for that.
I mean,
I'd consider it,
and if it,
if it had to happen now,
like,
yeah,
I definitely think about it and I'd probably lean more towards doing it and
saying,
no.